Hey, everyone. Hey, Brian.
Good to be back.
It's good to be back. I'm back in a place with somewhat controlled audio,
although I'm having a bunch of tree work done,
and one of those giant tree grinding machines is literally outside my window.
However, I got a new microphone, and I believe it didn't even pick it up.
It's ridiculous.
So there's a bunch of onboard software stuff built into the mic,
and it might not even affect us.
Does it have a bunch of AI in there so they can correct your grammar
if you say something wrong?
That'd be cool.
That would be cool.
No, but it has noise gates and noise reduction and high-pass filters and stuff like that.
With that, let's go ahead and kick this off.
Hello, and welcome to Python Bytes,
where we deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 382, recorded May 7th, 2024.
I don't know if you caught it last time, but I was a year behind last year.
So I said 2023 last time I was doing the show intro.
But no, it is in fact 2024, despite what I believe about time.
It seems like it's going too fast.
Nonetheless, May 7th, 2024.
I'm Michael Kennedy.
And I'm Brian Okken.
And this show is brought to you by Scout APM.
Check them out during their segment.
It really helps support the show.
Connect with us on Mastodon.
All three of us are over there.
Links are at the top of the show notes.
If you want to be part of the live recording,
pythonbytes.fm/live.
Usually Tuesdays at 10 a.m. Pacific time.
And finally, Brian, I know we sometimes talk about our newsletter,
but people are subscribing and they're getting a lot of value out of it.
So if you want an artisanal handcrafted digest of all the stuff we talked about in the show,
deliver an email form so it's permanent right there.
You can forward it, share it.
All you got to do is head over to pythonbytes.fm,
click the newsletter link right in the center of the screen,
and then bring you to the friends of the show.
Keep your email private.
We don't share it.
We don't do anything weird with it.
We just want to be able to send you stuff about the show.
So people are really getting a lot out of this, Brian.
I checked last week the email that you sent.
Yeah.
Normal.
If you're doing good, if you're lucky,
if people really want to hear from you,
there's a chance that about 20% of people will open emails
that you send in the newsletter form to them.
The one you sent was like 95% opened.
That's awesome.
That is so awesome.
Thank you, everyone, for actually caring and subscribing.
So pythonbytes.fm, click on newsletter,
and sign up for it.
That'd be great.
Yeah.
With that, yeah, go ahead.
One of the things I wanted to bring up is,
so now there's two ways.
Then if there's something that you heard on the show,
but you can't remember what it was,
you can search your inbox if you save it.
Save our old emails from us.
But we also, we haven't talked about it a lot,
but the search box on pythonbytes.fm is excellent.
It searches both the show notes and the transcript.
So even if it wasn't listed, but it was said,
it might find the right episode for you.
So it's pretty cool.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, I use that.
I actually use that to decide,
oh, if we talked about this thing before.
Three years and I already forgot about it,
or should I cover it, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Amazing.
Amazing, amazing.
All right.
So we jump in to the first topic.
Well, I want to act on that information
with a product called Act.
And it's from Necto.
Necto's, I think it's the person's,
maybe just their name is Necto,
and it's their Act.
N-E-K-T-O-S-A-C-T,
but it's in the show notes or in the email
that you'll get if you sign up.
Anyway, what it does,
it's super cool.
It runs, what it's doing
is it's running GitHub Actions locally.
So if you could set up,
you could set up this.
What you have to do
is you have to install it,
and it's got great installation instructions.
I used Homebrew,
but it's got installation instructions
for Chocolaty or even GitHub CLI.
I could have used that
or Mac boards, Scoop.
I didn't know what,
I don't know what Wingate is.
Anyway, getting...
Wingate is,
you know how on,
for example, on Boutique,
we have ApptGet,
Debian Systems sort of thing?
So that is the,
for a long time,
Chocolaty was the package manager.
It was kind of like Homebrew,
sort of external for Windows,
and Wingate is like
the official Microsoft package manager
for Windows.
Oh, okay.
It's kind of a new thing.
I don't use it very much
because I don't use Windows enough
that I care about that stuff,
but yeah, that's what it is.
Cool.
Well, so this project,
really what it does
is it's,
you can run your workflows locally,
but you have to install it
and you have to set up Docker locally.
So it could,
because it uses Docker,
which actually I kind of love anyway.
So what it's doing
is it's running your actions.
It loads up a Docker image
and runs your actions.
But the control over it's really pretty cool.
So I should have looked this up,
but there's,
you can,
there's different runners,
but the way you run it
is there's a bunch of different commands
that you can run.
So you can run,
run your pull requests
or you can run a specific job.
There's a whole bunch of different,
different parameters for this
to be able to run different pieces.
I used it just to run.
I wanted to just check,
check my test,
test run within locally.
And because I wanted to play
with the different test jobs
and coverage,
be able to run those individually.
And it really was slick
and it's super fast,
really easy to use.
It's really pretty cool.
It's also open source.
So nice.
We're going to link
to the GitHub repo as well.
So you can check it out.
And it's,
apparently I'm not the only one
that loves it.
It's got 1.3 thousand stars.
So that's forks.
50,000.
Oh, that's forks.
There's 50,000 stars.
Nice.
It's awesome.
This is so awesome.
If you do a lot of with GitHub actions,
this is so cool.
one,
you can sort of test it
and run it faster
and iterate really quickly
till you get it dialed in, right?
Yeah.
Then the other thing, Brian,
that might be interesting,
there was,
I don't know,
I'm kind of inspired a lot
by what the 37 signals
people are doing
around deployment and stuff.
One of the things they did recently
is they moved their
continuous integration.
Maybe even using this,
I don't know.
Moved their continuous integration
to developer machines.
So instead of having,
you know,
one server where all the builds
just queue up
behind each other.
It's like,
everybody has a super high-end
computer is oftentimes faster
than the CI servers anyway.
So run it there
is like a pre-commit hook
sort of thing.
Yeah.
Or, you know,
some sort of push,
some kind of event locally.
And so this,
it kind of lets you go down
that workflow as well.
If you're like,
we just want to distribute
the compute so we can make
our actions run a lot faster,
at least a good chunk of them,
you know?
Very neat.
One of their ideas for this also
is to use it as a local task runner
instead of like make
or things like that,
which is interesting.
You could have workflows
that aren't reachable from CI
that you can just run locally
through,
through this if you're already using it.
That's really awesome.
This is great.
I love it.
All right.
Well, so since you brought up Docker,
let's keep going.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
I'll get there in a second.
So I'm sure you're familiar with Ngrok.
We've talked about how Ngrok
is awesome before
and it solves a super interesting problem.
So Ngrok is a commercial project.
I'm a big fan of it.
I'm a pain user of it.
We'll see if I continue to be honestly
after I read this out.
However,
I'm a big fan of it, right?
So there's all these situations
where you need to easily get access.
Something on your machine
in terms of an API or a website
needs access to the internet
just for testing
or just for a demonstration purpose.
Like how often are you,
you're in a Zoom meeting
and somebody's like,
hey,
I want to show you this new design
and this new user interaction.
So let me share my screen.
And then they're like on a huge monitor
and it's blurry
and you're like,
I think I like it.
I don't know, you know.
But with Ngrok,
you just say here,
just everybody connect
to my little local dev app
and click on this
and see how you think it feels, right?
Or you want to debug a web hook
which has to come from the internet
to somewhere public
so you can just fire up
an Ngrok endpoint
or use SSH
to tunnel
what would be regular web requests
into your machine
that turn back into web requests
to hit Flask or FastAPI
or whatever it is, right?
I did it for web hooks a bunch recently
and also for mobile apps.
Oh, yeah.
When Lauren and I were building out the mobile apps,
they had to talk to
and just sort of do some callbacks
and other things
and we were testing out the API
and just like,
here,
we'll fire up an Ngrok
and he'd be on his phone
running the app,
clicking with it,
debugging it,
and it would be coming through the API
hitting breakpoints in PyCharm.
Awesome, right?
Yeah.
But it's more of an individual type of tool
and also closed source and paid.
Not that those are terrible,
but they are,
you know,
that's what they are.
So I want to tell you about Porter,
like P-O-T-R,
which is an open source Ngrok alternative.
So the idea is exactly the same
that I just described.
However,
the way it works,
don't watch the videos,
they're very bad.
Go to the docs instead.
Similar though to Act,
it has not as many,
but 2000 stars.
How old is it?
Six months old
for a six month old project.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
So basically to set it up on the server,
you have to have,
it says a virtual machine.
You need a machine.
This could be,
it could be a VM on the internet.
It could be a VM locally.
It could be a real machine
sitting,
you know,
on a,
on a beat up laptop in the corner
with a public IP.
Who knows?
Whatever.
You needed some kind of
pretty lightweight machine,
you know,
$10,
$5 digital ocean server.
You got to set up a cloud fair,
Flare token for wildcard
because it manages
subdomains automatically
and GitHub credentials
to log in.
And then that's it.
And the idea is that
it actually does,
it's built for teams as well.
So teams can manage
different ways
to call back into things
and connect things
and so on.
So it's got like a whole
team dashboard
and people can set up
the teams and whatnot.
But basically,
you just set this up
and you run a Docker container
on a simple machine
and then all of a sudden
you've got your own,
very own ingrock
where data also
is not going through ingrock
but it's just
private to you,
of course, right?
Because it's HTTPS
over to SSL
and then back.
Okay.
So when you're,
is that,
is it setting up,
like ingrock,
does ingrock set up a Docker?
Does it go through
dockers also?
No.
They run the server side
for you.
Okay.
They probably use Docker
but they completely manage
the server side for you.
You just use a CLI
that like talks
to that thing
and then sets up
a connection,
an SSH connection
back to you.
Okay.
And then when I'm debugging it,
if I set a breakpoint
or something,
do I need to set that
in the Docker image
or do I need to?
No, no.
The Docker image
is just a pass-through.
Oh, okay.
Got it.
Yeah, yeah.
It really does work
just kind of like ingrock.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's super, super similar.
I haven't used it yet
but I'm looking to start
trying this out
and then for the client,
you just,
there's a couple ways
to install it
but pretty straightforward
and then you just,
instead of saying Docker,
sorry,
instead of saying Docker
HTTP something,
you say Porter
HTTP something
and off you go.
Nice.
All right.
Yeah.
Pretty cool.
It sure is.
You know what else
is neat, Brian?
I think Scout is neat.
Scout.
Scout APM.
Scout APM is pretty awesome.
Let me tell you real quick
about Scout APM.
They're big supporters
of Python Bytes
so we appreciate that very much.
So if you are tired
of spending hours
trying to find
the root cause
of issues
impacting your performance,
then you owe it to yourself
to check out Scout APM.
They're a leading
Python application
performance monitoring tool,
APM,
that helps you identify
and solve performance
abnormalities
faster and easier.
Scout APM
ties bottlenecks
such as memory leaks,
slow database queries,
background jobs,
and the dreaded
N plus one queries
that you can end up
if you do lazy loading
in your ORM
and then you say,
oh no,
why is it so slow?
Why are you doing
200 database queries
for what should be one?
So you can find out
things like that.
And it links it back
directly to source code
so you can spend
less time in the debugger
and healing logs
and just finding the problems
and moving on.
And you'll love it
because it's built
for developers
by developers.
It makes it easy
to get set up.
Seriously,
you can do it
in less than four minutes.
So that's awesome.
And the best part
is the pricing
is straightforward.
You only pay
for the data
that you use
with no hidden
overage fees
or per seat pricing.
And I just learned
this, Brian.
They also have,
they provide
the pro version
for free
to all open source projects.
So if you're
an open source maintainer
and you want to
have Scout APM
for that project,
just shoot them a message
or something
on their pricing page
about that.
So you can start
your free trial
and get instant insights
today.
Visit pythonbytes.fm
slash Scout.
The link is in your
podcast player show notes
as well.
And please use that link.
Don't just search for them
because otherwise
they don't think
you came from us.
and then they'd stop
supporting the show.
So please use our link
pythonbytes.fm
slash Scout.
Check them out.
It really supports
the show.
Indeed, indeed.
What's next, Brian?
We've talked about
type annotation a lot
and I ran across
this blog post
called Annotating
Args and Keyword Args
in Python.
And actually,
I never tried that.
I've mostly just,
if I have
star args
or star star
kw args,
just sort of leave it
as is.
I don't,
I haven't tried
type annotating those.
So I was intrigued
as to how I would do that
if I wanted to do that.
And there's a
article about it
from Redawan,
I think.
What's his first name?
Anyway,
Redawan Delaware.
Cool name.
And it's the,
there's some
problems with all
the ways he tried
that seemed obvious.
Like,
sending,
passing in a dictionary
that he expected.
apparently my pie
doesn't like that.
Or doing like
a deck
sort of describing
the tuple
or a dictionary
that are coming in.
There were issues
with those.
The,
but I'm just going
to hop to the end result.
Apparently,
using,
using information
from PEP
589,
646,
655,
and 692,
there are features
like unpack
and type dict
along with typing
that we're used to
that are part
of the typing module.
And the,
the result
is kind of cool.
I mean,
it's not terrible.
There's a couple,
there's a pre 312
and a after 312 version.
I'm glad that he listed both.
But you,
you set up a,
a class
for your keyword args
and describe what the,
what the types are there
in your keyword
under type dict.
And then
for the
star args,
it's an unpack,
you say an unpack
of a tuple
and then the types
of the tuple.
So you can
do good typing
as to the,
the types of things
that you want
to come into
star args
or keyword args,
which is kind of neat
to make sure that,
I mean,
you think of star args
or keyword args
as just anything
can come in.
But if you really
don't want just anything
to come in,
this would be great.
So I like this.
Yeah,
it's cool.
It's a totally
reasonable thing to think.
Like I want to pass
one number
or two numbers
or a hundred numbers.
but whatever it is,
I want to operate
on numbers,
right?
Yeah.
Or yeah,
I want in this example,
it's either integers
or strings
that I'm going to get in
or insert pools.
So I would have
never come up with this.
The creator class
derived from type dict
with multiple values
to then wrap that
as an unpacked of,
okay,
I'm awesome.
They have it.
Yeah.
But this is,
this is amazing.
Yeah.
Seems like there could
be an easier way,
but anyway,
so this is pretty cool
and he's got
some great writing.
One of the other articles
that I started
down this rabbit hole
was a more recent article
from April 27th
called typos
does what I thought
type guard would do
in Python
and I don't use
either type guard
or typos
so I'm not sure
what these are.
But if you are
a type guard person,
maybe you want
to check this out.
Yeah.
All right.
That also looks cool.
Well done.
All right.
I have one more item
for us here
and it's pretty awesome,
Brian.
It's pretty awesome.
Awesome.
Ever since the,
the guy behind
just path
got thinking about,
hey,
people should use
the featured
on Python bytes
episode number badge.
I'm like,
oh,
there's probably more
to these badges
than I give them credit.
I mean,
I know I've seen
plenty of badges,
but there's a lot
of badges.
So this is a GitHub repo
with a thousand stars
that is a curated list
of GitHub badges
for your project.
And let me tell you,
what are you interested in,
Brian?
You want to talk about contacts?
You want to talk about groups,
socials,
operating systems?
Where are you streaming?
What kind of tests?
What kind of food do you want,
for example?
Well,
that's under the tests category.
I think that's the failed indent
I'm right here.
I think that's all just one thing.
I don't think that's this level.
I think the test got unindented
for some reason.
Okay.
What kind of terminal do you rock?
And so on.
Okay.
So I'll just go,
I'll pick a couple
just to give people a sense
because I don't want to just read
a list of a bunch.
But like,
for example,
you see the scroll bar,
Brian?
I mean,
this is a lot.
So under contact,
you've obviously got email,
but you've got,
if you want to be specific,
say,
hit me in my Gmail
or hit me up
on my ProtonMail.
You can actually have
those as badges.
You can have Signal,
Telegram,
Tutanota,
Noda,
however you say that,
WhatsApp,
WeChat,
all those things
are pretty cool,
right?
For groups,
you know,
Slack,
Discord,
Zoom.
Apparently,
I think Zoom is getting into like,
kind of trying to be more Slack-like,
even though I never use it for that.
Reddit and so on.
Under social,
that would be
Bitbuckets?
Social coding,
I guess.
I don't know.
But,
you know,
GitLab,
Instagram,
Pinterest,
Quora,
Reddit,
et cetera.
And then you've got some for the OS,
right?
Not just really standard ones,
but,
you know,
like CentOS or Deepin
or,
you know,
whatever.
But they also have their little icons
that go with them,
right?
Like the red hat is red,
but it also has the hat.
That is the red hat one.
And I'll just go down a little bit
and find some more of the uncommon ones
down here.
ETL,
that sounds boring.
like mobile frameworks.
So they've got like Flutter,
for example,
like the app I was just talking about earlier
that Talk Python is built on Flutter.
We could have that
or Ionic or Cordova
or,
you know,
Xamarin,
whatever you want.
So,
isn't that cool?
Yeah,
that's pretty fun.
What security platform is using?
Is it like,
this is verified by Snyk?
And so on.
Anyway,
so if you're thinking about your next project
or your GitHub profile or whatever,
I present to you many,
many GitHub badges for the taking.
Yeah,
let's see if I can get like,
like four rows of badges onto a project.
That'd be fun.
Exactly.
Well,
any other extras?
Wait,
this is one that wasn't your extra.
That's not an extra,
but I do have extras.
Okay.
I'll go,
I'll go ahead and go through them
since I already got my stuff on the screen for us.
All right.
So this one comes from the Django Not folks.
So the Django Not program is a program to help people who are interested in Django become core contributors,
not just users of,
but contributors to the Django code base.
So it's kind of like a mentorship program around that,
which is excellent.
And you must act soon.
You have six days to apply.
So the,
the session two application is open.
I actually interviewed Sarah,
sorry,
Sarah,
Boyce,
Sarah Boyce,
and Tushar Gupta about their experiences running and coordinating the first one,
right?
back on Talk Python in March.
Yeah.
March this year.
So if you want to hear more about it and you think maybe I want to apply to it,
well,
you've got six days to do so,
to be part of it.
It doesn't cost anything,
but there is an application process,
which is cool.
That was fun.
And then I was on Django chat,
the Django chat podcast with Will and Carlton.
And we talked all,
yeah,
I do too.
Those guys are both great.
And we talked all about this whole,
new deployment style and self-hosted open source and all these different things that I've been sort of talking on and off on about the show here.
But we spent a good chunk of the show just talking about,
you know,
how,
how am I running things for Talk Python and for Python bytes and for a bunch of other stuff.
And then what are some external projects and some of the other advice?
And it's just really fun.
So we had a good time talking to people can check that out.
Extras for you.
Yeah.
I'm going to start off with some bad news and then some good news.
So I came across this.
It's from bleeping computer,
but I saw it on a whole bunch of websites.
Fake job interviews,
targets developers with new Python backdoor.
And it's just,
it's just awful.
It's nefarious and evil.
And I,
you know,
the idea of a lot of viruses is to try to get people to run code,
sneak in stuff to run code.
They're just going straight to developers and saying,
Hey,
as part of the interview process,
we'd like you to download like this repo and run the code in there.
And then I don't know what they're telling to do after that,
but it's too late at that point.
At that point,
they've just run the virus.
So that's just awful.
Anyway,
be careful.
If you're,
if you're doing a job interview and they say,
Hey,
go,
go run some code.
Maybe don't,
or look into it a little bit more.
I mean,
it's so bad though,
because it could just be,
well,
all you got to do is pip install the requirements and take this project and
then add this little feature and show us how you did it.
Right.
that already runs arbitrary code from the internet.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It could just awful.
That wouldn't.
Yeah.
Yikes.
Anyway.
Okay.
So that's bad news.
Good news.
Good news is this,
this is the week that I'm going to switch the course.
Uh,
the PI test course is a complete PI test course is going from a teachable to a new
platform podium.
Um,
and it's just,
the reasoning is,
uh,
the,
you don't want to hear the reasoning,
but mostly it's the future of the,
that I'm working with for more courses and more things I want to do with
people teaching PI test and other things fits better with podia platform
than,
then,
uh,
then with teachable.
So,
uh,
to,
to sort of celebrate the switch,
I haven't made the switch yet.
It's going to happen this week,
but you can already get to this new one.
It's at Python test.
Podia.com.
And now through Sunday,
uh,
you get 25% off if you use the code PI test and,
um,
and that's P Y T E S T.
And you can,
um,
find that link in the show notes also.
Okay.
So,
uh,
and lastly,
um,
I know PyCon is coming up.
I won't be at PyCon,
but I,
um,
I know a lot of great people will be.
And so to celebrate PyCon,
I have a episode two 20 at Python test.
That's getting the most out of PyCon and some great,
and some great tips from Rob Lubwick,
Rob Ludwick,
um,
about,
you know,
having fun at PyCon.
So check that out.
Indeed.
Yeah.
I'm going to be doing,
um,
probably a data science panel podcast.
That's also going to be live streamed with,
uh,
the jet brains crew over there.
So that'll be a lot of fun.
Yeah.
And I will probably do Python bytes,
but since you're not there,
probably not an open space in person one,
probably just sneak away to a quiet spot and we'll do it like this.
Different background.
All right.
Awesome.
Is that it?
I had one more,
one last minute one,
which I thought was cool.
Just a,
one I just threw in.
Um,
I saw this on Amazon just before we started recording.
Somebody named Orion Reed,
uh,
posted this,
bookmarklet,
um,
that,
uh,
to visualize,
your DOM.
it's a JavaScript book market bookmarklet to visualize your DOM in 3d.
I love it.
So cool.
So it,
it may seem just like silly,
who cares?
But if you're looking at why is this thing overlapping that thing?
What about Z ordering?
Or why is,
you know,
this is actually contained in that versus next to that,
like all that kind of stuff you would see from this 3d rotational thing.
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
It's pretty,
pretty neat.
So I'll link to that.
That's all my extras.
So,
uh,
there's a question out there,
Brian.
This is an important one.
Uh,
who will carry the Python staff of power at PyCon and Brian,
who will do this?
I don't know.
I know,
but I think there's going to be a great disturbance in the forest is what I'm
feeling.
Speaking of which,
how about a joke?
Yeah.
I have two jokes for people.
One,
very heartfelt and sincere.
And we're going to close out the show with that.
But first one,
a sneaky little game.
So this comes from Reddit and it's just on our slash program and humor.
It's just,
just a little game.
And it says import random import OS randomly get a number.
Guess equals input.
Silly game.
Guess the number between one and 10 and it converts it to an end.
Right?
So you would think of course,
if gas equals number,
you won else.
Sorry.
You try again.
No,
if gas equals number print,
you won else.
OS dot remove.
So you could do it.
It's just terrible.
It would really work.
It would really work,
but you could do it.
Like you could delete your user profile,
you know,
like stuff that doesn't require admin access.
Oh boy.
That's funny.
Just a silly little game.
All right.
Let's close this show out with something special.
I saw this come,
come through the news a little bit.
So I think this is going to be a lot of fun,
Brian.
I came across this.
Actually,
you know,
this came from Dan Bader.
He sent this over to me.
Just said,
I think it was this said you wouldn't believe this.
Check this out.
And it's called permission granted.
A sad girl sings,
sings the MIT open source license.
Like for real.
Okay.
So it's AI generated,
which is what makes it crazy.
And it probably has Python involved in there somehow.
And since AI generated content can't be copyrighted,
we should be safe to plate.
Let's do it.
We're going to close out the show.
It's two minutes.
You can listen to it if you want.
If not,
feel free to mail,
but into the show is we're playing this.
So here we go.
Permission is hereby granted free of charge.
To any person obtaining a copy of this software,
associated documentation files,
the software to deal in the software without risk.
and to do so.
And to permit persons to whom the software is furnished to do so,
subject to the following conditions.
The above copyright notice,
the above copyright notice,
and this permission notice,
shall be included in all copies or substantial portions of the software.
The software is provided.
software is provided as is,
without warranty of any kind,
express or implied.
according to the warrant,
according to the warranties.
The warranties of merchant tabulating,
the law is,
the law is provided in all kinds of documents,
and the law is provided in all kinds of documents,
law enforcement.
So copyright holders,
be liable for any claim,
damages or other liability,
whether in an action of contract,
toward or otherwise.